Hello everybody first of all I'd like to
wish you all a very happy new year 2018.
I hope that practice is as fruitful and
enjoyable as possible
and that you will remain in good health for the whole year.
I'm doing this video today, this kind of vlog thing,
which is pretty unusual and as you
can probably tell,
I'm far more comfortable behind the camera than in front of it
but because 2017 been a such a big year
for the channel and that's you know 2018
looks pretty big as well,
I thought it'd be in order to go through what happened last year
and perhaps talk a little bit about what is coming up for the year to come.
2017 has been a good year for the channel,
it went through its 10th year of
existence (I've actually started in 2007)
and in 2017, we passed the 30,000th subscriber,
which is amazing considering that,
you know, Aikido is a kind of a niche
interest.
It's unlikely to go much higher than that
because the content I do
is pretty specific,
it's very historical, very factual and I
wanted to stay like this.
Indeed, I've received some advice from people, including from people from YouTube,
giving me advice on how to increase my viewership by
producing such and such type of content
but this is not going to happen because
the purpose of this channel is to be
the highest quality possible.
I live it to other channels to do perhaps more popular content,
but that that's fine, I do what I do.
So we've reached over 11 million views, which is quite a big thing.
Since people had been asking me how to support the channel,
I have open crowdfunding accounts one on Patreon and one on Tipeee,
so the most helpful, of course,
is to contribute financially,
Give a dollar, or more, if you can spare it per month,
And all that money will be re-injected into buying gear,
funding travels to conduct these interviews, and all the logistical aspects of it,
because of course what's important to keep in mind is that
everything I do I do out of my own pocket, in my own time,
this is a hobby I'm not a professional I'm not on anyone's payroll,
and that's very good, as it is.
It gives me freedom to do what I want, freedom not to do what I don't want to do,
and I'm basically putting most of the money myself
and counting a little bit on the ads that display at the bottom of the videos from YouTube to get me a little bit of money,
Patreon, even though it's not you know crazy successful, few people are donating
but I really appreciate the fact that those people actually decided to donate,
and some partnerships,
including the one with for example the International Aikido Federation
for which I'm Information Director
and of course IAF provides some logistical help
and sets up some contacts for me to do
what I do
and I provide an exchange some material for the Federation
so that's been working very well, especially with the new chairman, Kei Izawa,
he actually went as far as going with me to Iwama for example,
to conduct the interview with Isoyama Shihan.
Talking about those interviews of course
some major interviews came out this
year,
the one with Isoyama Shihan, the one with Tada Shihan,
and something a little bit different, the interview with Akuzawa Shihan, from Aunkai,
I hope that you guys found those videos interesting,
on top of the usual Budokan and Kagamibiraki demonstrations.
Finally I'd like to talk a little bit about the content that's going to be published next year.
I've got an interview with a pretty prominent teacher
coming up probably January, or
worst case scenario, February,
and two more, at least, which I can't talk about right now
because we're still in discussions but that it's 80% - 90% chance of happening
and of course that's going to be published during the year so you can really look forward to new content,
high quality content, and the channel is
very much going to continue like that.
To finish I'd like to thank you all very
much for following this channel,
for your kind comments, for your support,
financially for those on Patreon and Tipeee,
thank you very very very much that means
a lot that helps a lot
and once again, I wish you a very happy new year 2018 and all the best,
and I'll see you on the tatami, bye.